hello and welcome to your third WX
Python tutorial in this tutorial we're
gonna be talking about how to add a
minibar and buttons on that bar and then
items to that button so in this case
you've got this is the menu bar you've
got all these buttons on the menu bar
like help run options file and then when
you click one of the buttons you see you
have all these options to choose from so
in our scenario what we're going to do
is we're going to add a file button and
then an exit item to that file button so
with that let's hop right on in this is
where we left off now I'm going to get
rid of all this stuff here and we're
just going to say mirror this we're not
going to use size and then in here and
then the corresponding what we're just
going to say is we'll just put our like
literally args and kwargs and if you
don't know where args and kwargs are are
exist arguments and then kwargs
is keyword arguments but for now we're
just going to like literally just type
these in here and just leave them oops
squirms now the next thing we're going
to do this is just we just define the
initiation basically so the next thing
that we're going to want to do is let's
get rid of all this and we're going to
say self dot basic GUI so we're going to
start allowing a graphical user
interface right so now now that we've
done that obviously we need to define
this basic GUI so we'll define basic GUI
and then in the parameters self :
now what we want to do the first thing
that we're going to need to do is define
a menu bar object basically so we'll
just we'll call it menu bar equals and
then the definition for this basically
is W X dot and menu bar and then we'll
have no parameters now once you've done
that the next thing we need to do is
start to define this file button like so
here we've got file so
we need to start to create that so file
button equals WX menu so it's just
meaning it's going to go to the menu
then the next thing we want to do is
let's start the definition for the exit
item that we want so we're going to
literally just call that exit item
equals file button dot a pen
so you're appending some rules that will
apply for this file item to the this so
like when we click it so you'll
understand more in a second but we're
going to append it to it
so we're pending the menu item to the
menu itself right and what we're going
to do is W X dot ID underscore exit oops
all caps and then you specify what the
title of that button is going to be in
this case since it's an exit we're going
to call it exit and then finally this is
like at a status bar bench or what it's
going to say on the status bar let's see
if we have one here see even this Python
window doesn't have a status bar let me
pause this and let me open up something
that does have a status bar okay I
literally can't find any program of mine
that has a status bar on it but we'll
get to the point where we implement a
status bar basically right here is a
status bar like this grey area so when
you go to file and you hover over exit
it'll say like exit the program down
here so you can just be like I'm just
going to write in your status message
right like text is what it is well right
now we're not going to see that at all
because we don't even have a status bar
but later on when we do have the status
bar we'll need it so now we're going to
append the menu item to the menu itself
like I was saying before so we have menu
bar so this is just talking about menu
bar now what we want to do is append the
file button to that menu bar like this
is the file button we want to pan that
file button to the menu bar so a menu
bar dot append and then you're going to
pend obviously file button and then you
give the name of that file button like
we just give the name of this exit
button same
with file button you can do file another
little cool trick that you can do later
on it doesn't really work for me but
depending on like who's running the
program and stuff you can put like this
and sign here and what that'll do is
like I can't do it here like if I do
control it basically it will allow you
to do short keeps so like if you're on I
think like so far not so far sorry
like max and stuff like you can do this
so it'll make like a short key so you
can do like a short key and it will pull
down F so like I'll underline the first
letter of F so if you're on like one of
those operating systems then go ahead
but at least for me it doesn't really
work so anyway that's the name of the
button then the next thing we want to do
is we want to set the menu bar so right
now we've only defined the menu bar and
like we've said look at the menu bar is
a menu bar alright but we've not
actually like called it to action or
anything so now what we want to do is
self dot set menu bar and then you
define what you want the menu bar to be
which is menu bar and it just so happens
that menu bar is indeed a menu bar type
so that's good now what we want to do is
bind an event to a rave an event handler
to when someone clicks that exit like
what do we want it to do so in this case
what we're going to want to do is self
dot bind and we want to bind WX event
menu menu and then we want it to do self
quit when it's clicked and what item do
we want that to be we want that to be
exit item now we haven't defined self
quit so now we need to define or we
haven't defined quit rather not self to
quit so now we need to define what
happens on quit but also while we're
here before we do that let's go ahead
and do self dot set title and you can
call this anything before we called it
like we set it down here but we're going
to change all this in a second so I'm
just going to delete that bottom or self
dot title and then we'll just say it's
an epoch window um then we'll do self
dot show make sure you use a capital
show and then we'll just put it true and
then now let's define quit so define
quit quit quit so II now you just do
self dot close and so now you've defined
what you want to do on close basically
or on that click what is it going to do
it's going to refer to this function of
quit then what's that do it just self
dot close next and the other thing you
can do like maybe later on will add to
it if someone clicks that you could
later on have a message pop up that does
like one of those like are you sure and
so you can kind of define like the
quitting process under here so like
right now all it does is close but later
on you can do some more interesting
stuff so finally I will come down here
to find main and as always you have to
have app equals something or well really
you can call app whatever you want but
you eventually need to have it be equal
to W X dot app and then we'll define
window class and in here we're going to
put none and again that just means that
it has no parent like it is the parent
and then finally app dot main loop and
then last but not least we'll run main
and let's see if we made any typos along
the way run okay did not make any typos
here is our window and as you can see
we've got a file and when you click on
file we have an exit option and when we
click exit it exits and that's it for
the program so still obviously very very
basic but just like before even with
just like the window all of these things
what's really nice is this really an API
right it's a Windows API
where you can use Python programming in
like Python I guess logic and setting up
you know that you're familiar with to
code window stuff because honestly like
just making a file button that does
things like has the hover option and
when you click it it opens up and we
need to exit it I mean that's a lot of
coding and to be honest we did it really
quickly so even though this is a really
basic stuff so far there are some really
cool things that we will continue
showing you but I just want to be clear
like how awesome this really is because
there's a lot of coding that goes on
behind the scenes with this because
again this is just like a wrapper over
really C++ so anyway that's it with the
exit button and stay tuned for more
videos thanks for watching